democrats continue to scream over
republicans voting on a trump supreme
court nominee
idolatry of rbg breaks out as democrats
target amy coney barrett's catholicism
and wells fargo ceo comes under fire for
saying something perfectly obvious
about lack of minority job candidates
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben so it looks as though republicans
have the votes mitt romney now says that
he is going to vote
at least in favor of the nominee if the
nominee is qualified which presumably
the nominee will be now even lisa
murkowski the senator from alaska
she is apparently giving signs that she
may vote for the nominee
because i haven't seen the nominee yet
but if i see the nominee and the nominee
is qualified
not sure why i shouldn't vote for that
nominee which leaves only susan collins
in vulnerable state in maine as the lone
republican who would not vote for a
trump nominee which means that
whoever trump nominates is likely to
pass with flying at colors
president trump signaled his pleasure
with this yesterday he praised mitt
romney so mitt romney uh
has this very weird career where he goes
from being good to bad and bad to good
and good to bad for everybody
um now he is on trump's good side
honestly i've always been
relatively warm toward mitt romney i
think that romney is an honest guy even
when i disagreed with a lot of the stuff
he was doing including how he voted on
impeachment
uh i i was not quite as uh sure as some
other people on the conservative side
word that romney was going to say that
he wasn't going to vote on this nominee
i just thought that that would be a
career ender for him and it would be
immoral
to me he was trump praising mitt romney
the senator from utah yesterday
we have great support from the
republican party tremendous support it's
never been this unified before ever
ever in the fake impeachment we had 196
to nothing republican support
and we had 52 and a half to a half in
the senate who was the half i can't
imagine
i can't but he was very good today i
have to tell you it was good
now i'm happy thank you mitt thank you
okay that's a little bit funny by the
way some of this seems to be having a
little bit of an effect in state polls
there are a couple of new polls out
today from abc news that show trump up
slightly
in arizona which would be a move that'd
be a real move in the polls for trump
shows him up 49 48 over joe biden in
arizona it also shows him up 51-47 over
joe biden
in florida which puts trump much closer
toward a path to
re-election i think everybody was sort
of assuming that arizona had escaped
trump come 2020's election meanwhile the
late night house are winding
you can always tell where the emotional
center of the democratic party base is
simply by looking at the late night
hosts who are aghast that republicans
would move forward with the republican
nominee when the president is a
republican and the senate is republican
here are a bunch of late night hosts
pretending to be comedians but actually
just being
essentially slightly more or maybe
slightly less
humorous than the hosts on msnbc
i get that the hypocrisy is baked in
pointing it out won't change their minds
it's like telling a middle school bully
giving me a wedgie won't make your
parents get back together he knows that
he just wants to give you that wedgie
it's truly amazing how mitch mcconnell's
rules
keep changing first it was oh we can't
nominate a supreme court justice during
an election year
and then it's like oh asterix that rule
doesn't apply when we have the white
house less than
two hours after we learned of ginsburg's
death we heard from
senate majority leader and neutered dog
sack
mitch mcconnell wow he called him a
neuter dog sack guys because he looks
like testicles
wow can you hear the human ring can you
hear the comedy
now the one of the questions here has
always been why the hue
and cry i mean seriously why the insane
response
to what is a perfectly normal operation
of government namely a seat comes open
the president nominates the senate gets
to vote on the nomination or not vote on
the nomination
as it sees fit but the the level of ire
over this
is so insane it can only be explicable
if you recognize
that for many democrats for many
democrats including reportedly religious
democrats
politics is the religion this is the
idol this is the golden calf
ruth bader ginsburg is not merely a
powerful figure
who is worthy of emulation in many views
of leftists she's a god-like figure this
is why you saw people screaming
crying to the skies this is why you see
people gnashing their teeth
rending their garments dousing
themselves in
in ash sitting outside the walls of the
supreme court i mean this is this is the
reaction and it is
completely outsized now again i'm i
remember when when justice
antonin scalia died and everybody was
very upset about this i mean this
happened in the middle of the 2016
election
and scalia was a far more weighty
justice than ginsburg was you just
to put this in context 100 years from
now no one is going to remember a single
decision that ginsburg wrote
you can't name a single decision that
ginsburg wrote right now okay ginsburg
was not an extraordinarily weighty
justice her career was weighty because
of the the power of women to rise to the
top ranks of american law although
sandra day o'connor had already been on
the supreme court for years by the time
that ruther ginsburg
got there so this this notion that her
confirmation to the supreme court
acted as sort of as a sort of push
forward for women generally was not true
i mean that that
supposed glass ceiling had already been
broken that's not to demean her life but
her judicial legacy is really
non-existent she does not have tons of
judicial legacy outside
of the realm of civil procedure where
she was a purported expert scalia
was a much more consequential justice
whose decisions will still be read 100
years from now
republicans were upset about it
republicans did not go into
the apoplexy of mourning and rage
that you saw over ginsburg they just
they didn't it wasn't a thing that
happened
i remember because i was there okay but
but democrats are pulling out
all the stops here i mean they are
treating this as though a saint
has passed away like an actual religious
aid not like she's a saintly person like
an actual religious saint has passed
away
which means that they are now going to
react to republicans attempting to
fill that seat with outsized outrage and
an insane
overreaction chuck schumer yesterday
actually blocked an intelligence hearing
a counter intelligence hearing so there
was an intel a counter intelligence
hearing that was supposed to start
it was supposed to be about election
threats democrats have been claiming for
years that republicans are going soft on
election threats
how much do democrats care about threats
to the integrity of american elections
they care so little that they were
willing to put off the hearing in a fit
of sheer peak
at the fact that republicans were going
to vote on whoever trump nominates who
is chuck schumer blocking an
intelligence hearing yesterday
on behalf of the office of the director
of national intelligence
that that meeting occurred during
today's session of the senate
is there objection observing the right
to object
democratic leader
reserving the right to object because
the senate republicans have no respect
for the institution we won't have
business as usual here in the senate
i object i object i objected we're not
going to do business at all we're going
to stop business as usual
because republicans have no respect for
the institution we don't do the things
the senate is supposed to do from now on
i mean this was the hallmark by the way
of chuck schumer's response yesterday
we love the senate so much that we are
going to stop all business in the senate
and also wreck the institution of the
senate
which suggests to me you don't love the
senate all that much and as i've been
saying for the past several days for
democrats
they like the senate when it is a tool
of power on their behalf they do not
like the senate when it is not a tool of
power on their behalf they like the
filibuster when it's a tool of power on
their behalf they don't like it when it
is not a tool of power on their behalf
they love the supreme court
when it is cramming down same-sex
marriage on the entire country
in direct contravention to both the
constitution of the united states and
state laws all over the country
they don't like it so much when the
supreme court is rejecting
their particular argument on the
constitutionality of rescinding daca for
example
so in other words the institutions are
only good when they do what they want
them to do which is the sign that you
have no
institutional allegiance at all you
don't care about the institution what
you care about is the power and
everybody knows it
which is one of the reasons why
republicans are unwilling to kind of
deal with democrats
in order to come to some sort of
conclusion here because why would you
trust anybody who hates the institution
so much they are willing to wreck it in
the first place
i mean here was chuck schumer yesterday
again reiterating this thing they're
ruining the institution of the senate
they're ruining it
they're ruining it so much that i would
like to get rid of the filibuster which
has been around and in use since 1837
and i want to add states to the senate
willy-nilly with democratic senators
that's how much i love the senate all i
want to do is completely skew it
leader mcconnell's actions may now very
well
destroy the institution of the senate
if leader mcconnell presses forward
republican the republican majority will
have stolen
two supreme court seats four years apart
leader mcconnell has basically decided
the rules don't apply to republicans
even their own rules it's just brute
political force
okay first of all let's point something
out if chuck schumer were in charge of
the senate in 2016 he would have rammed
through merrick garland
he wouldn't have waited let's stop
pretending that he's going to abide by
the so-called mcconnell rule and
mcconnell by the way did say
at the time that when the parties are
not the same for the president and the
senate
that that makes a difference in this
calculation but again
the notion that the democrats are the
great senate defenders the institutional
defenders
beggars the imagination it's truly wild
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that you're
overpaying for cell phone bill you are
okay it's just a fact you're paying too
much money the reason you're paying too
much money probably you're paying for
that unlimited data and you're probably
not using unlimited data because by
definition it's unlimited and you cannot
use unlimited data
you probably don't need it what you
actually need is a program from
talk pure talk will give you the exact
same coverage the same towers the same
bars but it will cost you half
no contract no excessive fees you're
gonna save yourself a ton of money
right now enjoy a limited talk text and
two gigs of data
all for just 20 bucks a month the
average person is saving 400
a year on their wireless bill so grab
your mobile phone tile pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you'll save
250 bucks off any iphone including the
new iphone se again
that is pound 250 say keyword ben
shapiro
pure talk usa simply smarter wireless go
check them out right now why would you
spend too much on your cell phone bill
when you literally do not have to there
is no reason to do it at all you can get
the same coverage
again same bars same towers but it'll
cost you half the money when you switch
over to pure talk usa
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro and when
you do you save 250 bucks off any iphone
including that new
iphone se pure talk usa saving you time
and saving you money go check them out
right now okay so the the democrats
continue to push forward this notion
that they are deeply deeply upset with
the
very basic constitutional function of
fellowship pete buda judge
who apparently knows nothing about how
the constitution works or how
voting works he tweeted out we're in
danger of a majority of justices on the
supreme court being chosen by presidents
who didn't even get the majority of the
popular vote
any way you look at it we're getting
less democratic by the day
okay so note if you're talking about
majority of the popular vote bill
clinton never won
a majority of the popular vote jfk did
not win a majority of the popular vote
woodrow wilson did not win a majority of
the popular vote
they all got to appoint justices in fact
of the democratic president since the
turn of the 20th century
the democratic presidents who have not
won the popular vote have appointed some
11 justices to the supreme court during
that time
also if the great problem here is that
we are in danger of justices being
chosen
by popular minorities you know who's
okay with that the founders you know i
know they were okay with it
because they did not give the function
of judicial confirmation to the house of
representatives
which is staffed by population they give
it to the senate
which is fundamentally not based on
popular representation
if they had actually wanted the function
of confirming justices
to be put in the hands of the popular
assembly they would have put it in the
house they didn't they put it in the
senate
so thank you booty judge for yet another
example of your complete
ignorance about how constitutional law
works that's really exciting stuff but
again
what this really goes back to more than
anything is the levels of idolatry that
democrats have for politics
because if you believe that you are this
far short of utopia utopia's ever
receding of course because you never
reach it
but if you are this far short of utopia
and doing your part
and fulfilling your religious obligation
and then you have a setback
well that's a day of mourning that's
like in the jewish calendar tisha b it's
like the destruction of the temple
and i i've never seen anything made more
clear than this
by a there's a video from a congregation
reformed congregation
in new jersey okay this is a i guess
it's called temple
neritamid now let me make clear my
opinion of reform judaism i think that
reform judaism is currently constituted
has almost literally nothing to do
with traditional judicial traditional
judaism in any way
except that occasionally reform judaism
suggests that you wear some of the same
funny accoutrements
as people who are orthodox but reform
judaism does not strictly abide by any
form of
doesn't abide by jewish law it has
nothing to do with jewish philosophy
it it really is just progressivism
masquerading as religion but
it's not masquerading as religion it's
progress progressivism as the religion
it's not progressivism pretending to be
religion even it is progressivism is the
religion and adherence to progressivism
must conquer all if you want to make
your way into heaven then what you have
to do is declare your fealty
to progressivism and progressive icons
progressive saints
you have to do your do your penance to
progressivism
i've never seen anything made more clear
that the substitution of progressivism
for judaism which by the way has been
ongoing in the jewish community for an
extremely long time there's a vast
divide between how orthodox jews vote
for example and the rest of the jewish
community
orthodox jews can devote overwhelmingly
republican because it turns out that
biblical values tend to be a lot more
socially conservative
and a lot more pro-israel but
progressive jews meaning jews who by and
large do not believe
very much in in jewish religion they
kind of like the cultural judaism aspect
they like to they like the bagels they
like the locks they like the matzo balls
they every so often they like to go to
synagogue mainly so they can hear people
sing for like an hour and a half and
then they break on yom kippur
for lunch you know that that is not
judaism as a religion in fact it has
nothing to do with judaism as a religion
it is basically just some sort of
cultural solidarity
unlinked in any serious way to
underlying jewish values or jewish
philosophy
progressivism is the religion and then
you just slap a little bit of
jewish kind of flavoring on top you see
you slap a little bit of matzo ball soup
and some and some schmaltz on top
and then you're like oh well i guess
this is judaism now okay that's that's
what reform judaism has become
even more reconstruction is judaism
conservative judaism uh it doesn't
really exist anymore conservative like
old style jewish theological seminary
judaism it's broken down into modern
orthodox and then
and then into reform and
reconstructionist the reason i bring
this up
is because this is the greatest example
of substitution of
progressivism for religion i have ever
seen so this temple near tamid
again it is a reform synagogue in new
jersey
the rabbi of the congregation gets up in
the aftermath
of ruth bader ginsburg's death and
his name is mark katz he stands
alongside a cantor named meredith
greenberg
and they decide to do the haftarah so
the hafthora for folks again who are not
versed in jewish ritual
the hafftora is a segment that you read
after the torah reading so every
saturday
and on holidays you read the a section
of the torah
you've heard me on this show before do
you know full-on analyses of the torah
portion of the week
serious section of the torah and then
because for a long time particularly
during the the
roman period jews were barred from
reading from the torah
the jews added a haftura meaning that
they added a segment from
the nivea that from the uh from the
prophets from the writings and the
prophets
and that was supposed to substitute sort
of for the torah reading and then
eventually when the torah was allowed to
be read again you'd read the torah
reading and then you would read a
section from the prophet
okay so the haf torah has its own
special sort of cancellation it has its
own sort of trope
and trump are sort of the the way you
sing it
so this temple decided i i it's beyond
it's beyond blasphemy what this is they
decided that they were going to
substitute
for the words of the prophets instead of
a segment from
isaiah or a segment from ezekiel or a
segment
from the book of samuel or something
they were going to substitute the
writings of
ruth bader ginsburg a woman whose
most prominent stances were fairly
obviously
not in favor of of judaism she was a
very strong cultural jew was ruth bader
ginsburg and
that's wonderful and fine but ruther
ginsberg's rulings from the bench were
largely in favor of abortion on demand
and restrictions on religion via the
hand of government and then
if you're going to talk about her in a
religious context that that's where she
was so they decide that they are going
to
read the a half torah right they are
literally going to take the words
of ruth vader ginsberg substitute them
for the words of the prophets and then
sing them to the same tunes you would
sing
the actual jewish prophets in a
synagogue
okay this is not only blasphemous it is
a perfect
a perfect crystallization of the
substitution of progressivism
for religion it's it's especially for
the jewish community unfortunately it
has also happened
in a wide variety of other communities
ranging from the catholic to the
protestant it is obviously most
pronounced in the jewish community and
by far it is not close
okay so here is what this sounded like
when i saw this i couldn't believe it i
honestly couldn't believe it i thought
it was a parody
i thought it was something from saturday
night live it is so bizarre and insane
on every level
but this is a thing that happened this
is a thing that happened because when
politics is your golden calf when you
don't really believe in god
when what you really believe in is the
power of the collective to shape the
imagination
then this is what you end up with so
here are people donning the garb
of judaism in order to preach the words
of ruth bader ginsburg
all right here we go i
tell our students if you are going to be
a lawyer
and just practice your profession
you have a skill
very much like a plumber but if you want
to be
a true professional you will do
something outside yourself
something that makes life a little
better
for people less fortunate than you
okay uh a few things here gross
i mean truly gross using the using the
uh
the trappings and the and the halachic
accoutrements
to promote the verbiage of ruth bader
ginsburg from the deus in shul
is unbelievable levels of golden
calf idolatry in really like top-notch
stuff right there
on rosh hashanah really really well done
right there
okay and then beyond all of that i
challenge you
to recite back to me that quote was that
anything nearly as memorable as anything
from you know
the book of samuel either one or two
well was that anything
remotely memorable in any way but these
are the words of the prophets i mean
this is literally what this
doof said this doof said
women he said that she was a modern-day
prophet
she was a modern-day prophet and so he
decided to substitute
her words for those of you know actual
prophets
well i mean obviously she was not a
modern-day prophet she was just a
political leftist that doesn't mean
you're a modern-day prophet what is the
prophecy
exactly when one of the things prophets
are supposed to do is have an accurate
depiction of the future
i mean i can say that she obviously
would have liked to sit on the court
until a democrat was president
so i mean when we're talking about
prophecy not not so much prophecy
happening there but this was not rare in
the jewish community i'm gonna get to
more examples of this in one second
because again
the substitution of progressivism for
religion it is a religion progressivism
is a religion
in which there are saints and sinners in
which forgiveness
is never truly earned you're always held
to the fire no matter what
i'd say progressivism in many ways is
more like a cult than a religion even
at least in religion there comes a point
where once you've repented you are
cleansed of your sin in progressivism
you're never cleansed of your sin your
sin can always be brought back
up to you and thus used as a cudgel in
order to get you to do more progressive
things
that is the chief aspect of
progressivism that is that is truly
mortifying we'll get to more of this in
just one second first
if you've been listening to the show for
a while you've probably heard me talk
about my helix sleep mattress
it's fantastic right i mean i basically
would not sleep were not for the
quality of my personalized helix sleep
mattress well you know what helix has
now gone beyond the bedroom they've
started making sofas they launched a new
company called all form they are making
premium customizable sofas and chairs
shipped directly to your door
so what makes an all form sofa really
cool well for starters it's the easiest
way you can customize the sofa using
premium materials and at a fraction of
the cost of traditional stores
you can pick your fabric it is spill
stain scratch resistant the sofa color
the color of the legs soft size shape
make sure it's perfect for you and your
home they've got arm chairs and love
seats all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone
you can always start small and buy more
seats later on if you want your all form
sofa to grow and change with you when
you move we've got an all-form sofa at
home
it is fantastic it is durable which i
really care about since my kids wreck
everything all form sofas are delivered
directly to your home with fast free
shipping
in the past if you wanted to order a
sofa could take weeks or months to
assemble
or to arrive and then you'd have to have
somebody assemble in your home well this
takes just three to seven days to arrive
in the mail you can assemble it yourself
in a few minutes with no tools needed
i've got an all-form sofa
i picked out the three-seat sofa with
chase and the sand color with espresso
legs
it is beautiful and again it is
extremely durable all form
is offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at allform.com 20
off all orders at allform.com they also
have a forever warranty literally
forever and
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep this you've got nothing to lose
except your discomfort go check them out
allform.com
ben so unfortunately this particular
synagogue this reform synagogue in new
jersey was not the only one
that participated in this sort of
insanity
apparently at central synagogue a large
reformed congregation in manhattan
rabbi angela buchdall who's also a
cancer sang a hebrew version of leonard
cohen's hallelujah along a slideshow of
photos of ginsburg
by the way there's nothing quite like
honoring rosh hashanah by showing slide
shows
on rosh hashanah and uh and in the
process
also elevating ruth bader ginsburg to an
oscar tribute we're really
stellar stuff right there rabbi joshua
stanton of east end temple this is
forward.com reporting
another reform congregation in lower
manhattan heard the news minutes after
closing the synagogue's rosh hashanah
live stream on friday night
later that evening he joined an
impromptu zoom call where about 30
congregants remembered the justice as an
inspiration and exemplar
attorneys on the call said they had
modeled their careers after her stanton
recalled others worried aloud about the
sacred role sacred
role the court plays in our democracy
sacred it is not a sacred rule it is a
check and balance it is not a sacred
role sacred means ordained by god okay
that is not
a sacred role it can be a cherished role
it can be an important role it is not a
sacred role
the substitution of progressivism for
religion is one of the
great and awful developments of the 20th
century and it
is awful it is absolutely terrible
using again rosh hashanah which is one
of the high holy days in the jewish
calendar
in order to forward progressivism and to
elevate
ruth bader ginsburg into the sort of
high echelon of the prophets is pretty
incredible stuff
this is not relegated by the way to the
jewish community
it is not the way that progressivism
views religion is that
like everything else for progressives
tool
religion is a tool and it really is more
about the trappings of religion so that
you can pretend that you are allied with
the religious
rather than it is about the actual
doctrines of the religion in fact
anybody who says they are in favor of
the doctrines of their religion
is anti-progressivism and is therefore
some sort of blasphemer
right if you're a religious jew there is
nobody that reformed jews are more angry
at than religious jews
i mean seriously reformed jews when they
look at religious jews who take the
torah seriously and take jewish law
seriously
not to get in sort of the dirty business
of the jewish community the antipathy
that reformed judaism holds for orthodox
judaism is extraordinary
and the same thing is true in a lot of
christian communities progressive
christians
feel a lot of antipathy for evangelical
progressive catholics feel an
extraordinary level of antipathy for
religious catholics for more orthodox
catholics
see for progressives religion is
supposed to be about the trappings it's
not supposed to be
about the doctrine if you take the
doctrine seriously you got a problem
because the doctrine could be in direct
conflict with the progressive doctrine
and if those two are in conflict the
progressive doctrine right the golden
calf
and the actual religion then the
religion has to be torn down and you can
see this most obviously
in the way that democrats are preparing
to treat amy comey barrett so amy comey
barrett
seventh circuit court of appeals judge
she is a
an orthodox catholic has described
herself that way
she has seven children fi five of them
are natural born two of them are adopted
from haiti
by all accounts has led a pretty model
stellar life
clerk for justice scalia taught at
university of notre dame law school
is is really a great candidate in a
variety of ways and seems like a really
good person
she seems like a really good person but
she is called into question
because why according to progressives if
you refuse to follow the
sacred code of roe vs wade or if you
refuse to
signify your allegiance to the sacred
code of roe vs wade
and if you have signified that you
actually believe in god or you believe
in the doctrine of your particular faith
this means you are unqualified for the
court now let's be straight about this
you can be an excellent catholic and
still recognize the limitations of your
job
antonin scalia was a very very devout
catholic
he still recognized the limitations of
his job he did not use
his catholicism as a as a battering ram
for example against the death penalty
so the catholic church opposes the death
penalty last i checked antonin scalia
did not say
that it is unconstitutional to pursue
the death penalty he understood the
limitations of his job
his idea was that if i do my job
properly as a justice on the supreme
court
i'm not here to to make my doctrine law
if i do my job properly then i have
forwarded the kingdom of god
by both modeling good behavior and also
by forwarding the power and and liberty
of the united states of america where
people get to make their own decisions
religious people don't they're not all
theocrats
see for for progressives the
substitution of progressivism for
religion
means that there's a sort of
supersession theology supersession
theology is the idea that
you are the new religious you are the
new chosen so for many progressives they
are the new chosen
and that means that they have to get rid
of the old chosen the old chosen would
be
any form of any traditional religion and
so what that means
is that if you are a traditionally
religious person
we have to cast you as a theocrat
because progressivism
is in direct opposition to quote-unquote
theocracy
so instead antonin scalia becomes a
theocrat he can't simultaneously be a
good catholic and also a good justice
and you've seen the democrats already
start to say this sort of stuff about
amy coney barrett this is going all the
way back to 2017. so in 2017
dianne feinstein overtly said to amy
comey barrett who is being
at that point heard for the seventh
circuit court of appeals
feinstein chided her for being catholic
saying the dogma lives loudly in you now
again if you're
a catholic or if you're an orthodox jew
or if you're a religious muslim
i think it is perfectly plausible and in
fact the history of humanity shows
and that you can be any of these things
and also understand the limitations of
your job and what you are supposed to do
i mean last i checked this is literally
part of the new testament render to
caesar
section okay and i'm not christian under
under judaism that would be called dina
democracy meaning the law of the land is
the law
okay so this has been a long time
religious doctrine but for people who
are anti-religious or a-religious
their perspective on religion is that
religion dictates not only every aspect
of your life but also dictates that you
crammed down your religion on everybody
else
which is not something that religion
necessarily dictates in any case here is
dianne feinstein
progressive figure basically suggesting
that amy comey barrett cannot be a good
justice because she is a catholic
i think whatever a religion is it has
its own dogma
the law is totally different
and i think in in your case
professor
when you read your speeches
the conclusion one draws
is that the dogma lives
loudly within you
and and therefore she could not be a
good justice right she couldn't be a
good judge because the dogma lived
loudly in amy comey barrett
dick durbin did the same thing he asked
amy comey barrett about being an
orthodox catholic what's your definition
of an orthodox catholic now again
for uh is very funny hugh hewitt
who is a friend and radio host he
pointed out online
that democrats have taken a pretty
anti-catholic line throughout their
questioning of people like amy comey
barrett they did the same thing with
justice scalia the implication of course
is that if you're a religious catholic
then you're a theocrat
and kevin cruz who is a liberal
professor i believe at princeton if
that's correct
kevin cruz tweeted back well you know
look how many catholics have been in
positions of power in the democratic
party i mean
their last three vice presidential
nominees or catholics
most of the catholics who are in
congress are democrats okay that may
very well be true
and there are jews on the supreme court
too none of them are orthodox and none
of them
actually practice the doctrine of
judaism outside the court in any serious
way
okay just because you have people i mean
joe biden has been refused communion for
his position on abortion by particular
local churches nancy pelosi same deal
in other words what religion is designed
to do in this iteration is to be sort of
a cultural thing like you know you go
out on sunday nights and you get chinese
food and then on monday nights
you go to mass and you say a few words
and then you go back home and then you
talk about how abortion's wonderful
okay for a lot of religious people in
the country that is not how they view
religion that is not how they view what
religion ought to be
and so here's dick durbin questioning
amy comey barrett about orthodox
catholicism as though
orthodox catholicism is in direct
contravention of sort of liberal values
and that there's something bad about
being an orthodox catholic that makes
her
inherently intolerant the only true form
of catholicism that we should be
seeking to emulate is the kind where you
you mumble a few words in latin every so
often and then you go out at night and
do exactly whatever the damn well hell
you please
you use a term in that article or you
both use a terminate article i'd never
seen before
you refer to orthodox catholics what's
an orthodox catholic
um as i recall that term
we said something like for lack of a
better term we're using the term
orthodox catholic and there was a long
footnote saying you know that that was
an imperfect
term do you consider yourself an
orthodox catholic
i am a catholic senator durbin i i don't
well orthodox catholic we kind of
as i said in that article we just kind
of use that as a proxy
it is not to my knowledge you know a
term currently in use but if you're
asking whether i take my faith seriously
and i'm a
faithful catholic i am okay so again the
fact that
you have to be questioned about being a
faithful catholic is really quite crazy
i mean it's i thought this went out with
like jfk but again jfk i guess
would not have been considered an
orthodox catholic is the idea so the
idea is that
you're an anti-catholic bigot if you ask
a democrat about their catholicism but
if you ask
a a an orthodox catholic about their
catholicism it's not anti-catholic
bigotry
whatsoever by the way both dick durbin
and dianne feinstein
both defended themselves on charges of
anti-catholic bigotry
over all of this stuff way back in 2017.
they said it's completely fair
they said it's completely fair to go
after people for their catholicism we'll
get to that
in just one second first as we slowly
adjust to a new normal we need to be
smart about how we do business luckily
there is stamps.com to make things
easier thousands of small business
owners have discovered the benefits of
stamps.com in recent months
they've been able to keep their
businesses running avoid the crowds of
the post office all from their own
computers with stamps.com you can print
postage on demand you can avoid going to
the post office and
you will save money with discounted
rates you can't even get at the post
office
stamps.com also offers ups services with
discounts up to 62
no residential surcharges here at
dailywear we've been using stamps.com
since 2017. we don't waste our time and
we don't waste our money
they bring all the mailing and shipping
services you might need directly to your
computer in the comfort of your home or
office
whether you're a small business sending
invoices an online seller shipping out
products or just working from home and
need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle all of it with
ease it's a no-brainer it really is
they also offer ups services with
discounts up to 62 percent
no residential surcharges right now my
listeners get a special offer includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale
no long-term commitment if you're just
wasting money and time there's really
re-evaluate yourself reevaluate your
company we at dailywear been using
stamps.com for years we've saved a lot
of money
head on over to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro again that is stamps.com
enter code shapiro to get started
okay so again dianne feinstein and dick
durbin they have actually
defended this in the past suggesting of
course that
what they were doing was asking
legitimate questions about whether you
can be a good catholic and still be
on some of the nation's highest courts
and we are seeing mazie hirono do the
same thing
and she she's attacked judicial nominees
for their faith before
asked if her religious view should be
off-limits according to cnn
senator senator hirono said no she said
no they absolutely should not and
we have now seen two count them two
articles one from newsweek and one from
reuters
suggesting that because justice uh just
because judge amy coney barrett
was part of a self-described charismatic
christian community called people of
praise
this means that she is a character from
the handmaid's tale
i'm not kidding this is what the the
argument is so the argument is
she is such a handmaid and she is of
whatever her husband's name is
she's a handmaid and she's such a
handmaid that she serves on the seventh
circuit court of appeals now i've read
that book i don't remember any of the
women who are being used
as vessels for childbearing being
members of some of the nation's highest
courts or being nominated for the
supreme court but
forgive me if i forget that part of that
stupid book and the book is indeed
incredibly stupid so
again religio truly religious people
have to be excoriated by the left
true religion according to the left is
reading ruth bader ginsburg
from the pulpit on rosh hashanah let me
just say if you are substituting
politics for your religion
you're not talking about eternal values
you're not talking about
a living a deep and fulfilling life
because every time something does not go
your way
on this mortal coil in the world of
politics it becomes a deep threat
to your own worldview it ratchets things
up
and one of the great developments in
human history was in the aftermath
of the protestant reformation there are
a bunch of religious wars between
catholic countries and protesting
countries and protestant
rebellions and catholic leaders and all
of this and the the treaty of westphalia
essentially said that there was going to
be
much much more religious tolerance in
europe and it ended a lot of the
religious warfare in europe
for centuries and warfare came out in
other ways obviously but
religious warfare was basically put on
the back burner because everybody sort
of said okay we're gonna have to
acknowledge
that we exist religious warfare is truly
awful
as you can see in the muslim world
between shia and sunni it's really bad
religious warfare
turning politics into religion is not
going to make things better it's going
to make it a lot worse and this is the
direction we have moved sec
human beings have a religious need one
of the great developments in
civilizational history
is the recognition that social fabric
built through religion could be separate
from what the government is supposed to
do
reading back into what the government is
supposed to do all of the religious
things that you want
is a form of theocracy but that
theocracy these days is not coming from
the right it is coming almost entirely
from the political left in this country
and it's really ugly and it's really bad
for the country and it's really bad for
religion
by the way which has become completely
secondary the golden calf remember was
not supposed to be
next to god it was an idol it was
supposed to be a replacement for
and that's what progressivism for many
folks has become okay meanwhile
stupidest controversy of the day
yesterday
so a wells fargo ceo quote-unquote
ruffled feathers
why well his name is charles scharf he
exasperated some black employees in a
zoom meeting this summer
when he reiterated the bank has trouble
reaching diversity goals because there
were not enough
qualified minority talents according to
two participants he made the assertion
in a company-wide memo june 18th that
announced diversity initiatives as a
nationwide protest broke out following
the death of george floyd
well it might sound like an excuse the
unfortunate reality is that there's a
very limited pool of black talent to
recruit from sharp said in the memo
sheriff spent more time listening than
speaking during the 90-minute call which
he initiated and has not been previously
reported his comments about black talent
rubbed some attendees the wrong way
according to the two employees who spoke
on condition of anonymity
several black senior executives across
corporate america said they're
frustrated by claims of a talent
shortage and called the refrain a major
reason companies have struggled to add
racial
and ethnic diversity to leadership ranks
despite stated intentions to do so
according to ken bacon a former mortgage
industry executive who's on the board of
comcast
ally financial corporate well tower he
said he was shocked and puzzled
by sharp's comments he said if people
say they can't find the talent they
either aren't looking hard enough or
they don't want to find it
okay so this happens to be a statistical
lie
it happens to be a statistical lie that
there are people of
every particular racial group who exist
in direct proportion to their population
who are available for each particular
job it happens not to be true
okay it's true in nearly every industry
in the nba jews are really
underrepresented why not a lot of
qualified jews for the nba
that's just the way it works hey and
there are not a lot of qualified black
applicants for wells fargo
that is not because of innate ability
that is because of shortcomings in
familial upbringing is because of
shortcomings in the education system but
it remains a fact
and that is not on wells fargo wells
fargo doesn't have to just go hire
a random black person in order to meet a
diversity quota because they are a
company that has to run at a profit and
has to fulfill
job requirements the willingness to
completely
all of these articles about this wells
fargo ceo that they quote somebody who's
like
you know it's just insulting he would
say something like that it's just not
true he would say something like that
there's only one problem at no point
they provide statistical evidence
that black recruits are available in
wide numbers sufficient to their
percentage of the population at large
why don't they provide those numbers
because those numbers don't exist i'll
get into it in just one second but this
goes to a lot of the
sort of critical race theory nonsense
that we are being treated to these days
a lot of the anti-racism nonsense we're
being treated to these days again the
principal
idea of anti-racism is put forward by
robin d'angelo and ibrahmax kendi which
is now infused so many of our
corporations
is that any policy that does not result
in an equal outcome by group
is a racist policy that must be done
away with
what if there are other confounding
factors anti-racist policy just ignores
them this is a perfect example of that
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let's talk about how sometimes you need
a better employee sometimes you do
so for example you know every morning
speaking of my judaism
every morning i study with a rabbi let's
call him rabbi levy and let's say he's
fantastic he's great there's only one
problem
every morning he wants to chat about our
lives and so we never get any actual
learning done well at that point i might
want to go to zip recruiter and find
myself a rabbi who's actually going to
learn mission up with me
instead of chatting about current events
i'm just putting that out there rabbi
levy
and it's true for our daily wire
employees here too okay the fact is that
we have lots of daily wire employees who
are fantastic because they replaced ones
we're not so good via ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter will send your job to over
100 of the web's leading job sites they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology
zip recruiters scans thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience
and actively invites them to apply to
your job
zip recruiter makes hiring efficient and
effective with features like screening
questions
to filter candidates and all in one
dashboard where you can review and rate
your candidates
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zipper
career get a quality candidate within
the very first date right now to try zip
recruiter for free my listeners can go
to zip recruiter dot com
slash daily wire that is zip recruiter
dot com slash d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip
recruiter dot com
slash daily wire zip recorder is indeed
the smartest way to hire if you're
looking for a great employee if you're
looking for a great employer
zip recorders where they all connect go
do it we use it at daily wire ourselves
go check them out right now
as part of our daily wire audience there
are a number of ways to take in the
podcast by the way you can listen on
apple podcast spotify or another podcast
app
you may also watch our podcast on
youtube facebook or over at
dailywire.com but here's the bottom line
we are now making our content available
to you
wherever you watch or listen dailywire
members can enjoy our shows on apple tv
and roku so members can enjoy all of the
visual elements of this podcast and our
other shows on your big screen either
live around man
find the daily wire on apple tv or roku
and download today you have to be an
insider member to watch live
so head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
use code watch at checkout to get 15
off your membership purchase this deal
won't last long act fast if you want
live shows on your big screen plus the
one of a kind highly coveted leftist
tiers tumblr again that is dailywire.com
to get 15
off with codewatch download the daily
wear on your apple tv
and roku today you are listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so again there is this trend in
american thought that is deeply
disturbing and incredibly stupid which
is that if there is any policy and it
results in a disparity it's because
discrimination took place so this wells
fargo ceo is now under fire as i've been
mentioning
for suggesting on a phone call back in
june right it is now last i checked
september
so everybody sort of waited lurking in
the wilderness
to to spring this political trap on the
wells fargo ceo
it trended number one on twitter
yesterday because he said there weren't
enough qualified black
applicants to work at wells fargo
sufficient to staff them according to
percentage of the population because
black americans represent about 13
of the population far lower percentage
of wells fargo employees
and people like that's unfair that's
terrible there's only one problem he
happens to be correct now the media will
always obscure this
because again they wish to attribute all
disparities to discrimination as thomas
soul has pointed out in his book
disparities in discrimination
this is untrue and very often the media
will acknowledge it's untrue they'll
bury it in paragraph 17 of a piece but
they will acknowledge
that it is untrue that an equal number
of qualified applicants by percentage of
population are available so for example
february 2016
peace in the new york times why tech
degrees are not putting more blacks and
hispanics into tech jobs
technology companies employ strikingly
few black and hispanic workers
they blame the recruitment pipeline
saying there aren't enough of them
graduating with relevant degrees and
applying for tech jobs
yet the data show there are many more
black and hispanic students majoring in
computer science and engineering than
work in tech jobs so why aren't they
being hired
those who enter the candidate pipeline
fall out somewhere along the way
and the culture and recruiting methods
of tech companies seem to have a lot to
do with it the pipeline problem is not a
myth
black and hispanic students are
underrepresented in computer science and
engineering while program
engineering programs relative to their
share of the population while asian
students are overrepresented
yet the pipeline is still more fruitful
than tech companies make it out to be
among young computer science and
engineering grads with bachelor's or
advanced degrees
57 are white 26 percent are asian eight
percent are hispanic six percent are
black
according to the american community
survey data at the top 25
undergrad programs nearly 9 of graduates
are underrepresented minorities
according to the education department
data
but technical workers at google
microsoft facebook and twitter according
to the company's diversity records
are on average 56 white 37 asian 3
hispanic and 1 black one
issue is that black and hispanic
computer science and engineering grads
are less likely than white and asian
ones to go into tech jobs
well wouldn't that be one of the
problems
ten percent of black computer science
and engineering grads have office
support jobs
including administrative support and
accounting jobs compared with five
percent of white graduates and three
percent
of asians it also happens to be that
you're talking about
the top tech companies in america i have
relatives
who work for some of these companies and
let me tell you the screening procedures
for getting into google are
extraordinary to be an employee at
google you got to go through a
withering barrage of testing and not
everybody's going to get through
the attempt to suggest that all policy
is due to some
some systemic racism when it's pretty
obviously due to personal choice and the
consequences thereof
is really ugly and makes for bad public
policy and it's really stupid
here is some information from georgetown
university georgetown university did a
full study
of black american college majors and
earnings it turns out
that the number of people who are
majoring
in that among black americans
stem degrees are not in the top 10
they're not in the top 10
for bachelor's degrees computer and
information systems like 14
is computer and information systems
that's like the highest
health and medical administration
services 21 human services and community
organization 20
social work 19 public administration 17
criminal justice and fire protection
15 i believe that this same study showed
that
stem degrees it was like seven percent
of black americans major
in the stem fields well that's gonna
have some pretty significant
ramifications for how many of them end
up actually working at wells fargo or at
google
by the way you know what's not listed
among these top ten would be anything
having to do with finance
again the rest of the top ten is
sociology computer and information
systems human resources and personnel
management interdisciplinary social
sciences
and pre-law and legal studies as it
turns out
the industry's most likely to have high
earnings
the majors that are most likely to have
high earnings for black americans
tend to be the majors that are least
taken
by black americans the top earning
industries are pharmacy pharmaceutical
sciences and administration
industrial and manufacturing engineering
chemical engineering electrical
engineering mechanical engineering
computer engineering
civil engineering nursing general
engineering and computer science
those industries i don't think a single
one of those majors
actually is listed in the top 10 that
black americans tend to take
that's going to make a difference in
terms of earnings but you see
when we are attempting to forward a lie
and the lie is that america is racist
and the proof that america is racist is
in disparity
then you have to ignore actual
statistics in many of these cases
now there is good news which is that
this philosophy is now being fought back
on by the by the trump administration
so yesterday the president signed a full
executive order abolishing critical race
theory from the federal government the
military and all federal contractors the
federal contractors is a big one because
it means private companies that contract
with the federal government
can no longer do the ibram ex candy
robin d'angelo diversity
training re-education malice struggle
sessions
under the uh under the executive order
the president explains our nation was
founded on the ideal that all men are
created equal and denounced as critical
race theories pernicious and false
belief
that america is an irredeemably racist
and sexist country this is according to
christopher
ruffo who's been reporting on this for
city journal among other places
the ambition of the executive order is
breathtaking the president will prohibit
federal funds from supporting critical
race theory trainings in the federal
government in the military
and by all federal contractors
furthermore the executive order
allows you to sue your company
if your company is creating a hostile
work environment
according to the executive order the
attorney general should continue to
assess the extent which workplace
training that teaches the device of
concepts set forth
in this particular executive order may
contribute to a hostile work environment
and give rise to potential liability
under title vii of the civil rights act
in other words
if your boss brings in somebody to
to train you that all white people are
racist is this a violation of title vii
of the civil rights act seems like
sure why not so i'm glad that the trump
administration is fighting back on this
but it goes to a broader guilt complex
that has been
promoted by the media in the united
states the suggestion of course is that
any disparity whatsoever
is attributable to white americans and
to the systems more broadly
and we're simply supposed to overlook
all the bad stuff that is happening in
the name
of this movement the most obvious
example of this by the way
was espn's max kellerman yesterday who
is just awful
stick to boxing max espn's max kellerman
blamed the riots in america's major
cities which have been
thorough going black lives matter and
antifa he blamed on right-wing
protesters because again
when you are pursuing a narrative the
facts simply do not matter at all
when he talks about like black lives
matter 93
of the protests are peaceful the vast
overwhelming majority are peaceful
and by the way the seven percent that
are not they have a very broad
definition of what's not quote unquote
peaceful like for example if you block
traffic or something like that or if you
respond to police provocation
and even then a big percentage of that
which we
that that wasn't peaceful is actually
outside agitators
extremist right-wing agitators posing as
protesters
in order to make the protests look bad
that's the first thing okay so just
making this stuff up again
when it comes to the narrative that
america is racist what that means is
excusing criminality in many cases
bailing out the criminals all right
remember kamala harris wanted criminals
bailed out of jail
it means overlooking the fact that many
disparities in american life
are created by personal choice or by
circumstances that have nothing to do
with racism and have much more to do
with class it means ignoring data
okay that is not the way any public
policy should get done in the country
unfortunately a lot of public policy
gets done
exactly that way okay meanwhile i got to
tell you
an awful story this is being reported by
the post-millennial
when you talk about black lives matter
movement and the good or evil of the
black lives matter movement this
is an unbelievably shocking and
terrifying story
and a tragic story in fact mia cathol
reporting for the post-millennial
in the wake of jacob gardner's tragic
death his close friend who organized two
since deleted gofundme pages for his
legal defense
spoke to the post-millennial about the
relentless doxing and defamation by a
leftist mob prior to the trump support
to the trump supporters suicide the
conservative 38 year old bar owner from
omaha nebraska
took his own life after a grand jury
indicted him for the fatal shooting of a
black man who assaulted his family and
vandalized
his storefronts among other enamoring
businesses amid george floyd protest in
may you may remember this case
there's a man named jake gardner he's 38
years old and the facts of the case
were caught on tape basically he came
out
with a gun to try and defend a business
and he was attacked on the street
and a confrontation ensued in which he
shot a
young black man and this was the cause
of
rioting it was the cause of major
consternation
and at the time the the douglas county
district attorney said that it was
self-defense
because the district attorney's name was
don klein he had determined
that the man who was shot a man named
scurlock i think his name was james
skurlock dived on gardner's back and
choked him according to the new york
post
gardner could be heard in another
bystanders video shouting get off me get
off me
with his right arm pin decline noted
gardner switched the gun to his left
hand and fired over his shoulder
the bullet hit skurlock in the shoulder
neck area killing him but klein buckled
after blm activists took to the district
attorney's house in july
demanding justice for skurlock according
to a friend of gardeners you can't tell
me a person
found completely innocent on the grounds
of self-defense was later found indicted
because of pressure and numerous
anonymous witnesses that came forth
against
jake later on i don't believe them to be
even credible in jake's death
i believe it's personally at the feet of
weak city officials and
and the mob rule according to the
coroner's toxicology report
methamphetamine and cocaine was found in
skurolot's urine that is the person who
was shot according to the omaha world
herald
scurlock was also stained by a
significant criminal history just 22
years old
according to an affidavit obtained by
the nebraska news channel they revealed
that skurlock was arrested in 2014 for
robbery and use of a firearm to commit a
felony
law enforcement officers implicated
skurlock's involvement in a home
invasion robbery as part of a group of
blackmails who entered the residence and
threatened four civilians at gunpoint
for drugs and money he was sentenced to
three to five years in prison he served
less than a year
was released the following august
scurlock was found guilty of assault and
battery charges last year he served one
day in jail
the suspect additionally pled guilty to
third degree domestic assault past
february
completed a 90-day jail sentence now
after the shooting everybody simply
just decided that gardner was a racist
despite evidence that he was not in fact
a racist he was informed
earlier this week that he was going to
be tried
for murder his gofundme accounts were
taken down
he was targeted by black lives matter a
black lives matter activist group
contacted his place of employment with a
scripted man claiming to blackball him
in any of the companies he works for
justin stated that he had never been
targeted uh so viciously justin being
the friend
of jake gardner justin
justin tried to create a spot fun page
for jake gardner
and it sadly has now been turned into a
memorial fund because gardner
killed himself so again to recap this
case on may 30th he was confronted and
attacked by blm activists outside
gardner's hive bar in the old market a
neighborhood in omaha
while backing up he reportedly lifted
his shirt to show a handgun he cautioned
instigators he was armed then when he
was knocked to a puddle on the ground
gardner fired two warning shots in the
air attempting to rise to his feet
an 18-second scuffle broke out with
james scurlock and then gardner
shot skurlock gardner by the way is uh
is a military veteran
he killed himself after he was after
after he was told that he would be
charged he served two tours in iraq he
suffered two traumatic brain injuries
from combat that placed the veteran
on disability so
again there are consequences as it turns
out to labeling people racist without
proper evidence suggesting that they
have participated in murder
when they have not which brings us to
the case of kyle rittenhouse so people
are going nuts because last night tucker
carlson
had the temerity to show tape on his
show that
basically told the whole story of kyle
rittenhouse kyle rittenhouse is of
course
the 17 year old young man and i use
young man advisably because
once you're 17 you are in fact a young
man he
he's the young man who shot three people
at this
riot in kenosha and it was pretty
obvious from the tape
that it was self-defense it's i mean we
showed the tape at the time we analyzed
it moment by moment well now there is
new video
of of kyle britton house he came to this
particular protest hoping to offer
medical aid
apparently what happened is that one of
the people he shot
was going around lighting fires he was
following them around with a fire
extinguisher
at some point the guy who was lighting
the fire started chasing rittenhouse
another unidentified person started
shooting his gun into the air
written house was running away he was
apparently pinned between
a car and one of these rioters at which
point he shot
one of the riders and the rider died he
then tried to get to the police
he was chased down he was knocked in the
back of the head somebody attempted to
attack him with a skateboard another man
approached him
and pretended that he was going to try
and help him and then pulled out a gun
and then
rittenhouse shot that man in the arm so
he shot three people two of them died
the one who survived and had his bicep
blown off essentially
that guy has been treated by the media
as a nurse it doesn't matter that his
friend after visiting
the man who was shot said that the man's
only regret was not having murdered
written house
the bottom line is that according to the
media he's a white supremacist there's
no evidence by the way of white
supremacy anywhere in here none
here is what uh here's some of the tape
that was shown on tucker's show last
night
to prevent the total destruction of
their community
good samaritans united to guard local
businesses
among them was 17 year old kyle
rittenhouse
so people are getting injured
and our job is to protect this business
and part of my job is also helping
people if there's somebody hurt
i'm running into harm's way that's why i
have my rifle because i need to protect
myself
all three of the people who were shot in
these particular circumstances
uh were people with significant criminal
records which does not mean that
they necessarily should have been shot
it does mean that if you're going to
talk about the character of the people
who are being shot versus the person
who's doing the shooting there's a
wide disparity in character okay the
tape again
shows what happened and what it shows
that it's going to be
nearly impossible to convict kyle
written house of murder especially given
the fact that rittenhouse then after the
first shooting attempted
to go to the police and surrender to
police and inform them what had happened
here's a little bit of the tape of the
first shooting
as richard mcginnis began tending to
rosenbaum rittenhouse returned to the
scene and began placing a call for help
as the mob begins calling for the attack
of written house
he is forced to flee the scene
okay so he runs away and then obviously
the next shootings take place
the way that the media have treated this
is that he went to kill okay there's no
evidence at this point that written
house went there to commit murder in
fact the evidence pretty strongly shows
he went there
in order to perform other functions
should he have been there the answer is
no i've said it from the very beginning
written how shouldn't have been there
does that mean that you get to nail the
guy on a first-degree murder charge
absolutely not but again in order to
whitewash black lives matter and pretend
that black lives matter is a wonderful
movement and that antifa is really not a
problem they're just anti-fascists
it is necessary to make some human
sacrifices and if those human sacrifices
include people like jay gardner or kyle
rittenhouse blm simply does not care
they simply do not care they don't even
wait for all the facts to come out at
any at any point here
and yet they are being proclaimed by the
media as a wonderful movement now
i have to say most ironic story of the
day comes courtesy of alyssa milano
so she is a defund the police activist
according to the uk
daily mail she was quick to call cops
when she believed an armed gunman was on
her bell canyon property on sunday
morning
the call ignited a response that
included seven ventura county sheriff's
vehicles
one k-9 unit a police helicopter and one
la fire department team that sat
down the street on standby daily mail
obtained exclusive photos showing the
first responders coming to the aid of
the 47 year old
at her five bed six bath 8 000 square
foot 2.5 million
home in the upscale gated community that
sits just 20 minutes north of l.a
a neighbor told daily mail we first
noticed the helicopter circling overhead
very low
we knew something was going on it's
usually such a quiet community then we
saw all the police cars parked in front
of alyssa's home they had their guns at
the ready and they seemed very serious
alyssa and her talent agent husband said
they said had dialed 9-1-1 when they
heard what they believed to be gunshots
on their 1.39 acre property
they allegedly told the emergency
hotline the sound scared their dogs and
made them feel the gunman
was nearby they described the person as
male 40 years old with a long rifle
the two have been married since 2009 and
she she's used the enforcement of law
enforcement before i mean properly she
got a restraining order against a
stalker the search by
air and street level lasted over three
hours ended abruptly at 12 20. it turned
out it was a neighborhood teen with an
air gun
shooting at squirrels the male teenager
witnessed the emergency response later
realized he was the cause
and turned himself in and now listen do
i think that there's anything wrong with
somebody calling the police if you got
somebody
on your property walking around with an
air gun which by the way you cannot tell
the difference
in some cases between an air gun and a
real gun no i don't think there's
anything wrong with that unless you have
suggested that calling the police is in
and of itself
an act of evil and racism and that the
police are the problem
so alyssa milano deserves all of the
mockery that she is getting
it turns out that many of the same
people who believe in defunding the
police are very much happy to use the
police
when it suits their particular purposes
they don't have to live by the standards
they set for everybody else
okay we'll be back here later today with
two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haase our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
mitt romney vows not to block president
trump's supreme court pick president
trump makes the most serious recognition
of national rot
since the 1850s and the mainstream media
get caught
in a major blatant lie about amy coney
barrett
check it out on the michael knowles show